I can throw a football though can you
yeah well you get one up on me yeah you
can't do no you're you bold oh you like
bowling right all of it yeah yeah that's
good I think that's this qualification
here though isn't it I think it's a
sport now yeah should be you look good
you look happy
well last time I saw you was that New
Year's Eve in Niagara Falls it was
freezing cold yes
60,000 people out there and enjoying
your performance it's almost like you
like the cold is that what's going on
how do you prepare the music that you're
gonna perform in that short timeframe to
make sure the fans are excited yeah well
I mean my thing was to try and keep it
up predominantly up-tempo I get very
nervous playing in this situation
because you know they got to assemble
the stage in record time so it's not
like you've rehearsed it's fixed you
know what it is it works it's sort of
like let's throw it together quickly and
hugs everything works now you've been
really busy you just came off a tour
you're going on another tour and you're
having hits by hits by hits you have
right now we were which is number one
now in Canada oh no congratulations
meets in
[Music]
has a new album going it's coming along
really really good yeah I've been
working on it for a solid year I thought
not on the right I've been in the studio
quite a bit so yeah give a name for the
album I do we're going to announce that
down the track everyone has their own
definition of success and you've had a
lot of incredible success in your life
but what has been your own achievement
that you feel has been the biggest to
you I'm still getting to do it that
they're level I get to do it at and
that's really it that's all I ever
wanted to do is keep making records and
hopefully people wanted to come and see
in live that's the baseline of it all
and I still feel that way about other
artists I hear a song and they are on
airing another son oh so I want to go
see them in concert and I just want to
go and be with everybody and sing that
song now there's been a lot of biopics
this year with Queen Elton John Motley
Crue if there was a biopic on you who
would you want to play you know no clue
yeah Chris yeah that's a good one no
Chris yeah we're taking somebody taken
Heath Ledger if he was still around yeah
but you would be totally into doing a
biopic I know it's terrifying at the
same time from it trying to get your
life into two hours sounds an impossible
task the holidays are coming up which is
very exciting
yeah you just released this song as well
tonight
[Music]
you know it's a sexy song it's beautiful
do you have traditions at home we often
go to Australia Christmas because it's
our parents a little bit everywhere both
their moms are there it's also a summer
which is the nice time to go there I
don't know about traditions but the tree
is up and the decorations are up and the
cats been eating the tree and been very
sick
don't let your cat eat the Christmas
tree it's not good